I'm about to show you how I get results
like this, this, and this using a
strategy so simple that even a complete
beginner couldn't mess it up. This
strategy has three steps. First, you'll
learn how to find your key levels. Next,
we'll be confirming our entry. And last,
but not least will be trade management.
But here's the thing. Most traders
completely over complicate this process.
And that's exactly why they're bleeding
their accounts dry. I spent years doing
the same thing until I figured out this
approach that changed everything. So,
let me show you exactly how this works.
Starting with step one. First of all, if
you don't have a simple and repeatable
way to find your levels, then nothing
else matters. You could have the best
entry confirmation in the world. You
could have perfect risk management, but
if you're marking the wrong levels,
you're just gambling. And I had to learn
this the hard way. So, back when I was
unprofitable, I'd be sitting at my
charts marking what I thought were
levels. But here's what I didn't
understand. I was marking levels based
on what I wanted to see and not where
the big players were actually looking.
And that cost me thousands of dollars.
The first trait of a high probability
level is that it needs to have untapped
liquidity sitting above or below it.
Now, what does that mean? It means that
there's stop losses clustered at that
price point that large traders want to
grab before making their real move. Now,
I know what you're probably thinking.
Kyle, this sounds complicated, but I
promise you once you see this on the
charts, it becomes second nature. So,
let me walk you through the levels I'm
talking about. First of all, let's talk
about our trading sessions. Now, we have
Asian range, which is 8:00 p.m. Eastern
up until midnight Eastern. And then we
have London range, which is 2:00 a.m.
Eastern to 5:00 a.m. Eastern. So inside
of each one of these ranges, we have
session highs and session lows. So
inside of the Asian range, we'll have a
high and a low. And then inside of the
London range, we'll also have a high and
a low. So on top of these session highs
and lows, we also have previous day
highs and lows. And last but not least,
we have New York session, which is 8:00
a.m. Eastern up until 12:00 p.m.
Eastern. Now, this session becomes our
trading session. Now, when I sit down in
front of the charts, what I'm looking
for are the swing points that are being
created. So, simply put, a swing low or
a bullish swing point is a candle where
both the candle before it and after it
have higher lows. So, you guys can see
here for the bullish swing point, we
have a low, a lower low, and then a
higher low. So, this here creates our
bullish swing point. And vice versa, we
have a high, a higher high, and then a
lower high. And opposingly, a swing high
is a candle where both the candle before
it and after it have lower highs. So we
have this high, a higher high, and then
a lower high. So this point here becomes
our bearish swing point. Now these swing
points inside of these sessions and the
previous day become very very important.
So when I sit down in front of the
charts around 7 or 8:00 p.m. at night,
this is what I'm typically doing. I'm
sitting down and I'm marking out all of
the hourly swing points from this
specific trading day. So you guys can
see here that we've marked out our swing
low in here. We have another swing low.
We have a swing high and a couple
different swing highs up here. Here's
another example where I maybe I'm
sitting down on Friday getting ready for
Monday's trading day and I'm marking out
all of the swing points that are being
formed inside of this specific day. Now,
if we've taken out specific swing
points, I will not mark those. And one
last example here. Again, it's a Friday,
so maybe I'm getting ready for Monday's
trading day. What I'm going to do is sit
down around 7 or 8:00 p.m. at night and
mark out all of the intraday swing
points that I see on the hourly time
frame just to prepare me for the
following day. All right, this process
is very, very easy. It should be very
straightforward. It should only take you
5 to 10 minutes to do this across one
market. Now, if you follow multiple
markets, which I tend to do, maybe it
only takes you 30 minutes to 45 minutes.
So, just quickly scan across all the
markets that you're trying to trade.
Maybe you're trying to trade precious
metals, gold, you know, all these
different commodities, the index
markets, currency markets. It doesn't
take that long to sit down and plot out
all of the swing points. But here's
where it really gets interesting, and
this is the part that nobody talks
about, right? Finding the level is only
30% of the equation because once you've
identified where price might react, you
still need to confirm that big money is
actually showing up, and you still need
proof that your analysis is correct. So,
that's exactly what I'm going to show
you in step two, which is confirming the
entry. So, you've learned how to mark
levels, but how do we actually take
trades and make money? Because knowing a
level alone is useless if you don't have
a way to confirm it's valid. Now, I
learned this lesson the most expensive
way possible. There was a trade I took
back in 2019. I had marked out what I
thought was a perfect level. It had
everything I just showed you. Liquidity,
higher time frame, swing point. I was so
confident that when price approached
that level, I didn't wait for
confirmation. I just entered immediately
because I knew it was going to hold. and
the market swept right through my stop
loss and continued another 50 points in
the wrong direction. I lost thousands of
dollars on these trades because I didn't
wait for confirmation. And that's when I
realized the level is just an area of
interest. Confirmation is what tells you
the big players have actually arrived.
So what is confirmation? Confirmation is
price action that shows you order flow
is shifting at your level. It's proof
that the big money is taking the
opposite side of the trade from all the
retail traders who just got stopped out.
Now, after the liquidity sweep, you need
to see a strong move in the opposite
direction, not some weak, slow grind.
I'm talking about a decisive candle that
closes back in the range after taking
out the previous swing point. Now, this
shows commitment. This shows that the
big traders are actually defending that
level. Now, let's talk about what proper
confirmation actually looks like. So,
here we have a bullish swing point and
price runs through that level. So, now
we just don't do anything. What we're
looking for is an actual closure of the
next hourly candle that confirms the
long. Now, we don't drop down into a
lower time frame chart until this hourly
higher time frame candle confirms that
we have a shift in order flow. And
opposingly, if we're bearish, we're
looking for this swing high to be rated
and then a closure back below into the
range to confirm the short. Now, if
these candles haven't yet closed and
they're just kind of wiggling around,
maybe there's 30 minutes, 45 minutes
left till candle closure, we are
absolutely not going to drop down into a
lower time frame until the hourly
closes. So, now that you guys know what
to look for as far as confirmation,
let's get into the actual trade entries.
All right, this day is November 24th and
it's a Monday. So, at the end of Monday,
right around 8 or 9:00 p.m., I will
typically sit down and mark out my swing
points. Now, if we miss swing points
overnight, we can always come back in
the morning and double check them and
plot our swing points just so we have an
idea of what's going on. So, not only do
we have these swing points, but I also
want to note that we are in this very
large sellside sign and balance. So,
maybe I am leaning bearish for the
following day. So, what we're going to
look for is obviously a raid on one of
these swing highs and then a closure
back below. So, let's keep fast
forwarding through until we get to New
York session. So, we're not looking at
anything yet. Right now, it's still
London session. So none of these trades
right now or none of this price action
to me is concerning. All right. Now we
have a raid on this swing high and then
a closure back in the range. So what
we're looking for is the following
couple hours. Then we can drop down into
a 5minute chart. So here we are
approaching 8 a.m. and it's still a
little too early for us to find a trade.
So let's just keep fast forwarding
towards equity open. All right, we have
our 8:30 candle. So we are about 1 hour
before equity open. Now let's keep fast
forwarding. All right. Now, we have a
fair value gap that appears and we are
in our session window. So, what I'm
going to look for is a retracement back
up to this fair value gap. All right.
So, we have our retracement back to the
fair value gap. What I'm going to do
here, and right now it's 850. So, this
is an opportunity where we could
possibly anticipate that maybe before
the equity open, we're able to position
ourselves expecting that the equity open
is going to send this market lower
because we already have what we're
looking for. We have a swing failure
pattern and we've closed back in the
range. And now we are approaching our
actual trading session window. So what
I'm going to do is place a short
position here. Obviously the stop loss
goes in a logical area. And maybe I'm
just going to target 2:1. So let's fast
forward. All right. Here's our equity
open. Obviously if we didn't get short,
we could have possibly looked at getting
short on this fair value gap after
equity open. And there we go. There's 2
R. Now, as you guys can see, let's say
if you didn't want to enter ahead of the
equity open, this was still a good
setup. So we had a retracement into this
fair value gap. We got a nice closure
here. So let's say if you want to go
short here, put your stop loss maybe
above this swing high, this 5m minute
swing high, and still target a 2:1.
Okay, this trade is giving you plenty of
opportunity. In fact, it ran 5R. All
right, here we have another trade
example. This is Friday, December 5th.
So obviously when we sit down, we're
trying to plan for Monday. And as this
market trades, obviously you guys can
see when I sit down at 8:00 p.m. or 9:00
p.m. Eastern, to mark out my levels
ahead of the weekend. What I'll do is
mark out all of my previous swing lows
and swing highs. And let's say we're a
little bit unsure of which direction the
market wants to go for the following
day. That's totally fine. We're not
looking for a very very clear bias. It's
okay not to have a bias with this
strategy. So let's keep fast forwarding
until we get to equity open. Uh right
here we have a swing point. So we can
mark out this swing high here as well.
So leading up into equity open, we have
our levels marked out. Okay, here's 5:00
a.m. 6:00 a.m. This candle closed at
8:00 a.m. This candle closed at 9:00
a.m. And then here we have a candle
leading up to 10:00 a.m. So here you
guys can obviously see we have this
swing high and we've closed back inside
of the range. Now this I am leaning much
more bearish on based on this hourly
candle, right? Because we've raided out
the swing high and we've got a nice
closure. So what I'm looking for now
that we've had our higher time frame
confirmation, this is the only time I'm
dropping down into the lower time frame.
I do not drop down to the 5minut time
frame until I have this higher time
frame confirmation. So what we're going
to do is drop down to a 5-minute chart
and see if we can get an entry. So here
we don't have any 5minut fair value gap
that we can look at. But what I do see
is a 5minut order block and a 5minute
breaker. So we have the low of this up
close candle and we have a breaker in
here. What I'm going to look for is a
retracement up into this level so we can
get short and then position ourselves
for a run lower. So let's see if we get
that retracement. All right, here it's
retraced. It's basically hit this level.
So, I'm going to anticipate a short
position here. Let's say we're going to
put our stop loss at maybe 50% of the
breaker. And again, we're just going to
target 2 R. Now, you guys can see here
that my target aligns with these swing
lows from the previous day. And that's a
good target to have. So, let's fast
forward and see if this trade pans out.
Right now, it's about 10:20 a.m. And
there we go. This trade eventually hit 2
R. And you can see the reaction after
we've swept out those swing lows. Now,
this trade eventually did make it about
3R. So, even if we entered a little bit
late or you didn't get the exact perfect
entry with stop-loss, there's still a
plenty of opportunity to position
yourself inside of this trade. Now,
let's say if you were only trading fair
value gaps, let's say if you wanted to
enter short on this one. Let's see what
this position would have provided you.
Let's say you wanted to enter here, put
your stop loss here. This trade still
would have provided a 2. Now, one last
trade example. We have Friday, which is
12th of December. And what I've done at
the end of the day, obviously, 7 8 9:00
p.m. Eastern. I've sat down in front of
my charts and I've marked out all of the
previous day swing points in preparation
for Monday's price action. So, what
we're looking for, let's say if we're
bearish overall, is we're looking for
one of these swing highs to be rated and
then we get a closure back into the
range. So, let's fast forward leading us
up to equity open here. Again, we have
equity open and as you guys can see,
we've raided out this swing high and
closed back inside of the range. So,
once we have this confirmation, then and
only then am I dropping down to the
lower time frame. So, let's hop down to
a lower time frame and see if we could
find an entry again. So here we have a
5minut time frame and now we have this
5m minute fair value gap. So what I'm
going to do is plot this out. You guys
can see the time of the entry 10:05 a.m.
right in our session window. So what I'm
going to do is plot a short position
here. Now let's say we're going to just
target 2 and our stop loss is going to
go above this high because we've already
traded up to the fair value gap high and
we're just looking for this continuation
lower. There we go. Now I urge you guys
all to go back into your charts and
study these examples. Plot out your
swing points in preparation of the
following day and do not look for an
entry on the lower time frame until you
get confirmation of that higher time
frame. But here's the thing, and this is
where I'm going to blow your mind. Even
with a perfect level and perfect
confirmation, you can still lose money
if you don't manage the trade correctly.
Because the entry is just the beginning.
What you do after you place the trade is
what separates the profitable traders
from the ones who keep blowing accounts.
And that brings us to step three, which
is trade management. Now, this is what's
going to make or break you. Because, as
you've seen, it's not that hard to mark
out a level and confirm it. The money is
made or lost after the trade is entered.
Now, let me tell you about my biggest
trading mistake. It was 2020, middle of
CO. I had finally started to figure
things out. Now, I found the perfect
setup on the NASDAQ textbook level,
perfect confirmation, everything
aligned. I entered the trade and within
30 minutes, I was up 200 points. I was
so excited, I took a screenshot and sent
it to my buddy who got me into trading.
But here's where I messed up. I didn't
have a plan. I just watched the trade
hoping it would continue running. And
you know what happened? Price pulled
back, hit my stop loss, and I walked
away with nothing. And not only did I
lose 200 points of profit that I had,
but I also took a loss on the trade
because I didn't move my stop, and I
didn't take a partial before lunch. Now,
that was the day I realized that trade
management isn't optional. It's
something you have to figure out on the
fly. And you need a system. You need
rules because when you're in a trade and
money's on the line, your emotions are
going to destroy you if you don't have a
plan. So the first rule of my trade
management is setting your stop loss in
a logical place. Not based on how much
you want to risk, not based on some
percentage of your account, based on
where your analysis should be wrong. So
for a bullish trade, your stop goes
below the liquidity sweep and below the
low that was just created. For a bearish
trade, it goes above the liquidity
sweep. Now you can dial it in even more
just as I showed you guys in the
examples on that 5minut time frame based
on fair value gaps or order blocks. But
you want to ensure that if you get
stopped out, it's because your analysis
was wrong, not because of normal market
noise. Now, I used to put my stop loss
in just random places because I wanted
to have more size on or I wanted to have
a tighter stop-loss with bigger
riskreward. And I just realized that
over time that actually hurts you more
than helps you. Now, second rule is
understanding your profit targets. And
this is where retail traders really get
it wrong. You're not just picking a
random spot on the chart and hoping
price gets there. You're targeting the
next logical liquidity pool. Whether
that's a previous low, previous session
low, or previous swing points from
yesterday, you're targeting the next
logical liquidity pool. So, as you guys
see here from that trade example, we did
have a 1 hour of inefficiency down
there, and we had previous swing points
that aligned with our targets. So,
before you place the trade, just ask
yourself, do I have a logical area that
I can exit this trade or take a partial?
Now, the third rule, and this one
changed my entire trading career, is the
concept of partials. Not only based
around price, but based around time.
Now, just remind yourself of this. You
don't have to be allin or all out. Okay?
When price hits your first target, let's
say we had some of those swing lows,
take 50% of your position off the table.
You lock in a profit and you guarantee
that the trade is a winner. Because not
only that, but then you can set the
remaining 50% and allow it to run to a
second target. Now, not only should you
have price exits, you should also use
time exits. If you're an intraday
trader, you need to understand that
you're giving a lot of money back by
trying to hold through the lunch hours.
And this approach solved some of the
biggest problems I had in my trading. I
was always trying to catch the entire
move. I'd be up 50, 75, 100 points and I
wouldn't take anything off going into
lunch because I thought it was going to
run 200 and then it reversed and I'd
lose and I'd find myself sitting in a
losing trade through the afternoon. Now,
with partials, you're capturing profit
while still giving yourself the
opportunity to catch those big moves.
So, as you guys can see over here, if
you took a partial based on time, so I
will always have in the back of my mind
when 10:00 a.m. comes around 11:00 a.m.
The further and further you hold that
trade into lunch hours exposes you to
time in the markets. And oftent times
around the lunch hour, we get these
massive retracements. Now, if you don't
already, put a clock on your desk. Start
keeping track of all the data behind
when a market moves and why it moves.
You're going to often find that a lot of
these markets die out before lunchtime.
And a lot of times these markets make
their move early in the morning and then
by lunchtime they kind of peter out and
die. Now here's what nobody really tells
you about trade management, guys. It's
not just the technical stuff. It's about
your psychology. It's about discipline.
Because the strategy I just showed you
is worthless if you don't follow it when
you're actually in a trade. If you're
holding that trade through lunch hours
when you said you were going to take a
partial and adjust your stop- loss, you
are doing yourself a disservice in the
markets. Now, let me tell you a little
story and experience that I've had in my
trading career. When I finally quit my
job in 2022, I had about 6 months of
savings to make this work. Now, that
pressure was extremely intense. Every
losing trade felt like I was one step
closer to having to go back to work. And
that pressure just made me do stupid
things. I'd move my stop loss further
away when a trade was going against me,
hoping it would turn around. I'd close
winning trades too early because I was
afraid of giving back profit. And I'd
revenge trade after a loss because I was
frustrated. Maybe I held that trade
through lunchtime. And it wasn't until I
stopped caring so much about the money
that everything changed. I started
following my rules no matter what. I had
logical stop- losses. I would trim
partials ahead of lunch hour. I move my
stops to break even when it was too late
in the day. Now, build those really good
habits and just rinse and repeat. Those
small changes is exactly how I went from
struggling to making my first $100,000
payout, then 500,000, and then over $2.5
million in one payout. It's because of
those small habits that I made. Now,
here's the reality. What I just showed
you is a complete strategy. You can take
this, apply it to the charts right now,
and start seeing results. But I also
know that when you're implementing
something new, you're going to have
questions. You're going to run into
situations where you're not sure if
that's a valid level or if the
confirmation is strong enough or when
exactly to take your partials. And
that's exactly why I created my private
community direct access to me where I
trade live with you each and every week.
I've helped students achieve results
like this, this, and this. And even
recently, one of my students made over
$75,000 in one month after struggling
for years. If you want that kind of
support while you're learning this
strategy, the link is in the description
below. I want to point out that spots
are limited. So, if the link doesn't
work, then spots are closed until the
next enrollment. As always, I hope you
learned something from this video.